the homes clean pocket throwing longing
which tiring
[Applause]
[Music]
67
hey Chris remember when we interviewed
Brett Beach last week and he talked
about how it's a good problem to have to
have all these great young players you
need to be paid starting with Patrick my
Holmes but continuing with Tyreke he'll
reportedly the Chiefs talking to Hill
about a new deal he's due to be a free
agent next year and I said earlier Chris
I'd want 20 million a year if I'm Tyree
kill Sammy Watkins is making 16 I want
20 yeah I get that I mean totally I mean
I think first of all it's really smart
the Kansas City Chiefs are trying to do
this right now right instead of Tyree
kil going out there and if he stays
healthy I think you and I would bet a
lot of money that he has another great
year with Patrick mahomes at his core at
quarterback with those two he's the most
explosive guy in football he's the most
danger he's the date most dangerous
weapon in all of football you could
argue and you know me I'm pretty into
football and a historian of football
where he I would argue it's him Deion
Sanders Bo Jackson Darrell Green for the
fastest people I've ever seen in the
history of the NFL that's how explosive
he is and that's Mike the point you made
about that's where Kansas City has put
themselves in a little bind I do think
they overpaid for Sammy Watkins I know
we said that last year in free agency
and here we are yeah you have a Tyree
kil who's definitely a notch up from a
Sammy Watkins and he's gonna go no I
want to be paid substantially more but
at the same time I'll throw this one
other caveat out there for this Mike
Tyree kill if there was ever a scenario
where a team or a player should give a
team a hometown discount I would like to
remind Tyree kill hey the Kansas City
Chiefs took a chance on you yeah
there's I don't know there was a whole
lot of teams that were going to take
that chance Tyree kills pre-draft off
the field stuff was very very
underwhelming I mean he did not exactly
look like the the classiest best person
we've ever seen coming out in the draft
the Chiefs took a took a chance in
taking him and of course it's worked out
so I would hope he doesn't hold their
feet to the fire too harshly I guess
what I'm saying there yeah but you know
what he look what he did was despicable
yes and and and if he had done it while
in the league right it would have been
gone forever he
did it before he got to the light he was
kicked out of college and and he found
around five because of it and now he's
part of this system and we just said in
the last segment get what you can
yeah wow you can and if they don't sign
into a long-term deal franchise tag next
year for Tyreke he'll and he can play it
out one year at a time after that if he
wants bottom line is this they have a
big cap number for Sammy Watkins this
year they don't have a big cap number
for Patrick mahomes this is the year to
load up the can and put a bunch of money
into Tyreke Hills pocket and a big cap
number on the table because next year is
when they're gonna have to pay Patrick
mahomes
next year I think Watkins is gone Tyreke
kills cap number needs to go down
mahomes is going to have a big deal I
say ideally as soon as the regular
season ends but ifs want to continue to
be dominant they need my homes and they
need Hill mahomes more than Hill yeah
that Hill makes my homes a hell of a lot
better exactly right it's the perfect
combination I mean you got a guy with
arguably the strongest arm we've ever
seen with the fastest receiver maybe
we've ever seen that means a lot of long
touchdowns
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports